it'll be spencer howard pitching today
for the rangers there's his combined
numbers this will be his third start for
this rangers team meritors have two
aboard for kyle seeger and the o2 on the
way to kyle down the line in a fair ball
into the corner crawford is coming home
with ease hanniger is into third and no
surprise kyle seeger drives in a run in
the first inning and it's one nothing
mariners that seeger stands up at second
drove in a couple yesterday in the first
done a really nice job hitting with
runners in scoring position this year
and here you go it's it down the line
midland able to keep it fair 300 career
doubles nice milestone for kyle now the
mariners have runners on at second and
third still nobody out a one to nothing
lead and here is first baseman ty france
france chops it over the mound here
comes ibanez on to first base as
hanniger scores
sega moves up the mariners hang a
crooked number here in this first inning
two nothing chris flexon making start
number 23 on the season it's his fourth
against the rangers mike the mariners
are 3-0 against texas when flexon is up
on the hill yeah he's been really
reliable this year for scott service a
10-game winner 3-7-8 e-r-a for flexin
126 in the third 85 strikeouts over 26
watts so a long at bat for dolis garcia
the count is still 1-2
got him this time finishes him off with
the breaking ball there is out number
one in the first strikeout for flexing
today gonna snap the 12-6 curveball on
him pick up his first strikeout well
located again down there at the bottom
of the zone delivery super moan a great
look at the 12-6 curveball one out two
on for low
on the ground
toro only plays on to first base two
outs hernandez into third counter
philipe at a second jonah heim
swing and it's popped up third base side
foul territory kyle seeger looking for
it he's there at the coaches box and he
makes the catch and the inning is over
and chris flexon works himself out of a
first aid jam now the mariners have
runners on it first and second with two
outs for mitch hanigar
down the left field line and this is
gone into the seats mitch haniger
an all-time career best 27th home run
this year congratulations to mitch
haniger who has helped to open this one
up in the second five nothing mariners
and it looks like here's the change up
at 79 miles an hour and he catches it
out front it's just a matter whether he
can keep it fair
so many times you get that far out front
you'll hook it foul but 100 on the exit
velocity just enough 372 feet as it goes
up into the seats and a career high in
home runs for mitch haniger turo flied
out to left his first time marin is a
five-nothing lead we've been wishing and
hoping as the old song goes for runs and
five runs on the board looking for more
swung on it ripped right field base hit
garcia will retrieve get it back in ty
france coming around and he'll score
without a throw and america's lead now
six nothing abraham toro with the rbi is
ninth since joining the mariner ball
club and it's another solid base hit
let's middle in at 93 miles an hour as
he turns on it barrels it up solid line
drive into right field exit v low of
102. ty francis base hit a 105. there's
jason martin leading things off
toro right place right time one down see
this line drive right into the defense
no problem for toro and the rangers six
nothing trailing in the ball game have
runners at first and third and one out
this ball
lifted out to right field bowers will
make the catch peters tags he'll score
easily as sac fly by martin and the
rangers are on the board it's a 6-1 ball
game
aggressive base running by peters gave
martin the opportunity and he cashed it
in two balls two strikes flexing way
over on the first base side of the river
hawaiian in the two two pitch this one
launched out to right field balance goes
back it's gone
number 27 for adolesce garcia that's a
6-2 ball game he needed that needed that
big time has been slumping somewhat
recently we haven't seen the power that
we saw earlier in the season and for
whatever reason whether it's gallow
being gone not having much protection
around him in the lineup but this is big
time power to the opposite field
chris flexing out here for inning number
seven he is pitched to dandy three
strikeouts one walk that walker raced in
a double play giving up a home run to
garcia in a sac fly to martin that's it
6-2 flex though one heck of a job
another strikeout for flexson as he
buries that in on dj peters one out
nobody on for brock holt
a weak hack and a miss back-to-back
strikeouts flexin retires the first two
here in the bottom of the seventh i'll
say this he's made the most out of the
opportunity thirty-fourth round and here
he is how about that yeah
one two three
[Applause]
to right center fraley giving chase on
the warning track and he flags it down
as flexin retires his side in order
seven strong a quality start for flexon
and arlington a chance to turn this one
into a laugher bags packed two outs for
kyle seeger no place to put him
and zieger draws the basement loaded one
not even close
fourth walk this inning bowers scores
seven two mariners lead kyle take the
rbi the second of the ball game for
casey has 24th appearance opponents
hitting 184 against him 22 innings he
has 19 strikeouts average basketball 93
miles an hour one ball and two strikes
over to the shift
crawford slings onto first off man
retired here is yani hernandez
chopped up the line
easy play for france here's shortstop
isaiah connor falefa mariner 7 rangers 2
bottom of the 8th
here's a swing and a ground ball to
short right there gobbled up by crawford
jp's throw to first plenty of time to
get kinder philosopher and that will
retire the side sadler one two three
bottom of the eighth low is on garcia is
on jonah heim to the plate over three
today this ball hit hard out to right
field that one could be trouble and it's
up against the fence
garcia to third they'll weight him to
the plate here comes the throw not in
time
and obama is in
[Applause]
great seeing this rangers offense that
will not quit using all of their at-bats
and trying to have quality ones
all game long they've been able to but
here in the night they lead off with
three in a row garcia low and then the
big double right here from
jonah heim love seeing it as well keeps
them out of the double play second and
third and a good opportunity for dj
peters to keep the line moving so he
bought as much time as possible makes
his move diego castillo will be coming
on now for the mariners rangers trying
to keep it interesting in this ninth
inning they have scored a run they have
two men in scoring position they've
knocked macevic out of the ball game and
now we'll get a look at diego castillo
okay so holt oh for three payoff way
outside that one gets away and here
comes
low he scores
seven to four that one got way away from
castillo it is a wild pitch martin now
last chance for the rangers he is the
tying run and one pitch
and that ball hit well out to right
field that could be trouble it's gone
a three-run shot
and the rangers have tied it in the
ninth
jason martin's fourth home run of the
year a lot of strikeouts for garcia
smith ahead one and two
to seeger toro onto first base high
throw and he's safe at first throw back
across playing third base and they got
him at third they got him at third base
what a play that was close runner at
second two outs bottom ten score tied at
seven
routine fly ball to straight away center
we go to the 11th
thanks in large part to just a fantastic
double play
see what ty france can do france looking
for his third hit today
smoked out to left carrying back and
gone
home run air france
11th inning lead mariners back in front
by freely fraley
yeah the base hit on the ninth inning
and that ball hit high in the air out to
right field back near the wall fort
garcia and he got it
what a catch by angolies garcia timed it
perfectly needed every bit of his reach
to bring that one back now once again
tonight the rangers down to their final
out
first pitch to obanios abanez out to
center fraley sizing it up and this one
is in the books but the mariners win it
in 11.
you